and the hits just keep on coming oh yeah
on the heels of the whole change to the
Terms of Service that happened with
YouTube that I already did a video on
linked up there it's now becoming
clearer exactly what might start
happening as we get nearer to Coppa
coming into effect so I got a background
and explained before I even get into any
of this
so Coppa Copp a it's an acronym I don't
remember what it's for what it is is
this is federal regulation that is
designed to protect children from
certain types of entertainment that
would be considered or feared to be
harmful to them it's actually not a new
law it's been on the books for a couple
of decades now the thing is it gets
updated and refreshed every 10 years it
actually wasn't scheduled to get updated
for a couple more years but pressure
from parents groups hat around YouTube
specifically pushed things forward and
it is revisions I think were made public
the it the whole thing is still in these
sort of public commenting phase of the
entire thing and there's that it's not
finalized but effectively this will go
into effect on January 1st so that's the
first thing it needs to be explained
even though I'm talking about this
through the lens of YouTube
unlike the Terms of Service Agreement
YouTube has no control over this YouTube
has a certain amount of control in terms
of how they are going to try and keep
everybody compliant with this but this
is not YouTube's rules this is federal
law which actually means it is much
higher stakes
then the Terms of Service was and I know
that sounded like high stakes cuz people
were concerned about losing their
channels trust me stakes are actually
on this so what is Coppa intending or
designed to do the new things being
added to it well basically it is it is
requiring that things intended to be
marketed towards or the which hold an
appeal for a child audience be
designated as being that and then doing
so will kick a few things into place
it'll do things like disable
notifications going out to your
subscribers that the view that the video
has gone online it's going to reduce ad
revenue because the kinds of
advertisements that can be run on
children's or on children orientated
programming is much more limited so it's
gonna cut into that and some people if
you have any videos up on YouTube you
have probably received a notice that you
need to mark both your channel and your
videos as to whether or not they are for
kids
so again the intention of this is to
help ensure that what kids are seeing is
stuff that they that is okay for them to
see the problem has to do with how
broadly this thing is currently written
which again was also the problem with
the YouTube Terms of Service issue I'm
not gonna break it down into specific
wordings on this the way I did on that
because this is this is federal wall
legalese which I'm not as good at
deciphering as I was with the Terms of
Service stuff so in this case I am
relying a bit more on summations and
articles that I read about it normally
I'd be going more to the source but like
it's long and it's complicated and it's
it's clumsily written and I don't think
I would get any more out of trying to
decipher that than what other people
already have so if I already mentioned
you know if you are if if a piece that
you've made is intended for kids or
appeals to kids keep an eye on that
phrase we'll come back to that then it
needs to be marked as such and as I said
that is
to negatively impact that video and
probably your channel so the issue then
becomes well what if I don't market what
if I didn't make something for kids well
your intended audience doesn't matter
because if it is believed that the video
that you have made holds appeal for
children and would draw them in as an
audience even if it is not your
intention to speak to them that still
needs to qualify as being children's
entertainment and subject to the same
restrictions now that sounds ridiculous
and it kind of is but the problem is
there isn't a lot of room for nuance and
context on this so any there there are a
lot of different kinds of channels very
freaked out about this because it's
obviously going to impact any channel
aimed at kids are not that is discussing
primarily or exclusively children's
media
so things that discuss animated movies
intended for kids things that discuss
toys or toy collecting or unboxing
things on you know squishies or slime a
lot of crafting channels they have
appeal for kids even if they're not
designed for kids and all these places
are going to be subject to this now what
if you don't mark something as being
intended for kids either because you
don't believe that it should be or
you're thinking well I just won't mark
that is for kids then it's all good
right well no no because if the video
ever gets reviewed and that first of all
it's clarified that is a big if the FCC
which is the organization behind this
they do not have the manpower to analyze
and look at every single video that's on
YouTube
they just don't so this is a big if it's
a bit like it's a bit like speeding in
your car doing it doesn't guarantee that
you're going to be caught because not
every road is being monitored at all
times bye-bye you know Town Car
the Highway Patrol or whatever but if
you do get caught it's not gonna go well
for you and it's the same kind of thing
here so if you do not have a video if
you have a video that is not marked as
being for kids and it is determined by
the FCC that it does hold appeal for
kids or if they believe you are
intending it for kids again whether or
not you say you're intending it doesn't
matter they will make that decision for
them selves then you personally are
subject to fines of up to and over
$40,000 per incident per violation so
what this means is like I said a lot of
youtubers are scrambling and panicking
right now in terms of setting all their
existing content to be marked as for
kids which I've already had to do I lost
count of how many I did I went back
through and basically marked everything
where I talked about discussed or
reviewed anything that was aimed at
children so basically every nearly every
animation junkie episode and you know
anytime I talked about Shira anytime I
you know my review of The Lion King you
know anything like that I have gone in
and manually marked it as being for kids
even though kids are never my intended
audience they never have been I still
need to do that because to fail to do
that opens me up to massive liability of
getting fine to just buried into the
ground by it because the FCC and they
have been asked directly about this has
been asked if they are going to hold
individual creators accountable or if it
they are going to target the platform
holders which is YouTube which has
already happy you to had to settle with
the FCC I think was last year maybe it
was earlier this year I can't remember
but they've already targeted the
platform holders now they have actually
said yes we will find creators so people
need to err on the side of caution very
very strong
now what does that mean in terms of
content new content be creative because
it's one thing to mark your existing
stuff but this could effectively put
many youtubers even some very sizeable
and popular ones more or less out of
business because it is going to eat into
what they're a you know the their reach
so much because marking it as something
being for kids is going to limit its
scale and scope and limit the ad revenue
and it's just gonna it's gotta kill a
lot of these places and again not
necessarily because that was the design
or the intention but it is gonna be the
fallout and I think it is more than
clear that the FCC does not care because
let's be honest most normal people to
say nothing of a federal agency like the
FCC believes that youtubing is a real
job it's not something they give a crap
about protecting so how does this impact
me personally and this channel going
forward well as I said I've already had
to mark a whole bunch of existing videos
as being intended for kids I don't think
it's going to too heavily mmm effect
what I will or won't upload I'll props
out like for instance I'm gonna take my
kid to see frozen to probably next
weekend and I will most likely do a
review on that and I will have to mark
it as something intended for kids now
part of this you know it has to do with
the fact that I I lean much more heavily
on my patreon than I do on my YouTube
income in terms of trying to get myself
to a point where this could be my living
and and patreon wouldn't be impacted by
this
obviously but so that's that's the first
thing other than that it's probably not
going to have an enormous impact on the
channel borrowing
two specific outcomes and these are
things that I am NOT going to make
preemptive changes but I'm going to keep
a very close eye on when the rules going
to fit into effect and how they are
being enforced so the two possibilities
that would definitely impact the way I
do this channel would be if doctor who
is considered to be children's
entertainment and therefore anything
talking about it would be considered
appealing to children and whether or not
my background which does feature toys is
enough in and of itself to get any video
in which this background appears marked
as being appealing to kids now in
regards to that second one I think it
helps that this background is not
excessively evident in my thumbnails and
like I'm not talking about these toys
they are however present and there are
some youtubers who have made the moves
do remove any collectibles or toy sort
of things from their background or at
least have said that they were gonna do
that I don't know how many actually have
that's something I'm gonna be keeping an
eye on like is that I'm not going to
preemptively dismantle my background but
I am gonna be keeping a very close eye
on that to see how that starts a panning
out and that will obviously affect my
presentation if dr. who gets considered
to be children's entertainment that
might I don't I honestly don't know what
I would do if that ends up being the
case because that is at this point half
my output out of four videos that I
released per week sometimes I do more
but it's a minimum for videos a week two
of those are Doctor Who related and so
if 50% of my output is suddenly clipped
and not easily found or viewable by my
subscriber base and is gonna be
receiving less monetization effectively
that's gonna put me in a tough spot and
may drive my reformatting some of what
the channel ends up being but remember
how
I talked about you know anything
perceived to be appealing to kids and
also me having the open question will
Doctor Who be considered for kids and
that's part of the thing this these
rules are super vague in terms of what
they consider to be appealing to kids
and with something like Doctor Who some
people call it a kids show I would call
it a family show i I don't believe it's
a program directly aimed at kids but if
the FCC in its infinite wisdom decides
that Doctor Who is this show for kids
than anything I'm a talking about it
needs to be marked as something for kids
and the lack of clarity because there's
a lot of gray area here like a lot of
the stuff I already marked Shira fine
Disney Pixar How to Train Your Dragon
fine I'm talking about something a piece
of entertainment that was made for kids
therefore my discussion of that thing
may come up in you know a kid's search
for anything related to that fine but is
Doctor Who for kids is Marvel for kids
is Star Wars for kids they certainly
appeal to kids they have large kid
fandom bases and the thing is we're not
gonna get a lot of clarity on this until
it starts being put into practice
because that's just the way the dang
thing's been written so the first thing
is if you yourself have any Content up
some people are removing all their
content which strikes me as excessive he
actually I'll back up your content
should not have to be removed provided
two things anything that has the
possibility of being considered children
targeted you haven't marked as such and
the contents of that video do not
venture into this clearly is not okay
for kids to see
so people who it may be in their best
interest to remove
content will be anybody say talking
about Shira and swearing about it in a
video they're probably gonna want to
take that down or any adult talking
about Sponge Bob Squarepants cuz it was
their favorite show going up and they
still talk about it they better not
curse or be making dirty jokes when they
talk about it a youtuber who I really
like um the Dom or it's Dominic noble I
think he just changed it to that he has
a number of review videos about
adaptations of children's media like for
instance he talks about the adaptation
of The Last Unicorn he does it for
neverending story and I'm pretty sure in
both instances he swears those videos
are probably gonna need to be taken down
and again like I do understand where the
guidelines for the rules come from
because unless you have marked an item
as for 18 and up only which is not a
feature of most people use and also
means he can't monetize it then if a
child is searching for something on the
last unicorn
they might get Dominic's video and it's
not meant for them but as far as the FCC
is concerned it doesn't matter
it would appeal to them which means they
might end up watching it and they
shouldn't be and unfortunately this is
just kind of an offshoot right now about
how this works so like in terms of
normal television which is what the FCC
is used to regulating that it's easy to
counter the what about the children
issue whenever you're dealing with say a
premium cable channel or airing past a
certain time of night so like Adult Swim
I mean Cartoon Network has a lot of
Appeal for kids but the Adult Swim block
which is very adult at times airs so
late it's not we
to expect the Cartoon Network to be
protecting children at one o'clock in
the morning they shouldn't have to and
they're not expected to but because you
can't control when someone comes across
yourself and if it's on YouTube it's
it's searchable and people can get it
and there are you know there is YouTube
kids which theoretically restricts kids
stuff and what they have access to but
you know how many people free and use
that you know so I get why but and I
don't I get I get the issue they're
trying to address but this is going to
screw over a lot of people potentially
myself included depending on how this
thing goes is there anything that can be
done honestly not really but if you want
to give it a try like I said the FCC is
still taking public comments I'll put a
link down below for where you can do
that if you do leave a public comment do
not make threats and do not curse you
will not be helping if you do that but
also you know between that and I like it
there's a change.org petition you can do
those things I have no belief that they
will help because we went through this
already with the FCC we went through
this with net neutrality where so many
of us worked so hard to bombard that
public comments explaining why the loss
of net neutrality was a horrible idea
they didn't listen they're not gonna
listen now either the public comment
phase of this thing is not because they
want our feedback it's because they're
required to do it to some degree they've
already decided what they're going to do
they're just going to do it and we will
know starting in January what this will
be like beyond that the other thing that
you can do and I mentioned this in my
Terms of Service video as well is if
there are content creators who you
strongly believe in and you greatly
enjoy their content
consider supporting them in whatever off
YouTube means that there is if they have
a merch store consider picking up some
merch if they have a patreon page
consider supporting them there this
platform has never been the most stable
thing in the world
and it's about to become far far less so
so if somebody makes content that you
enjoy and you want to help ensure that
they keep doing it whether it's me or
anybody else finding a way to support
them outside of the confines of YouTube
probably the best thing you're gonna be
able to do right now so that's my
thoughts and my breakdown of this
freaking mess what are your thoughts on
where they whatever they are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it buttons links like
subscribe all that usual stuff I do have
a patreon you might have guessed link
for that below we'll see what happens
I I normally try to end a little bit
feeling a little bit more upbeat but
this has the potential to wreck so much
and I don't think the FCC realizes that
what this is going to actually create is
far less children's programming on
YouTube people just won't do it because
it'll be so closely monitored and also
less profitable that will simply be less
of it and channels will move to creating
strictly adult entertainment there will
actually be less stuff for kids and I
understand that's probably the idea they
want to ensure that things kids
shouldn't be watching but even the stuff
that was designed for them a lot of us
gonna go away oh well whatever you feel
like doing about it links buttons
comments go ahead but you also don't
have to because at the end of the day
you are the council
I'm just running the meetings for as
long as I can continue to manage it and
until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]